ja willkommen zurück jetzt geht es
konkret um die Ethik des Internets und
wir nähern uns den virtuellen
Handlungsraum über das Phänomen des
Internets an
wir können also sagen dass wir die
ethische Bedeutung des Internets so
meine Thesen und dann angemessen
bestimmen können wenn wir es als einen
virtuellen Handlungsraum bestimmen
also Internet kommunizieren wir viel
aber Kommunikation ist immer auch eine
Form von Interaktion
das ist jetzt zwei Bedingungen voraus
wir müssen virtuelle Realität das habe
ich schon oft gesagt stärker als eine
bloße Simulation
Illusion verstehen in diesen Formen
kommt nur eine schwache ethische
Bedeutung zu und wenn Sie jetzt mit
einer Illusion zu tun haben
werden sie mal ihre Illusionen moralisch
sie können sie insofern moralisch
bewerten als sie sagen ich wurde
getäuscht von etwas das ist nicht okay
aber Simulationen
inwiefern sind die ethisch problematisch
hier kann man sich natürlich gleich das
Beispiel von Computerspielen vorstellen
ich kann natürlich unmoralische Dinge
simulieren
aber ich simuliere sie ja nur mach sie
dadurch nicht selbst es gibt
Computerspiele da kann man sehr sehr
schlimme Dinge tun also man simuliert
sehr sehr schlimm
die werden dann häufig indiziert von der
USK der Unterhaltungssoftware
Selbstkontrolle
da mache ich oben rechts auch ein Link
rein zu einem Video wo ich das zum
Computerspielen gesagt habe
auf der viel Cologne die werden
indiziert weil sie vielleicht auch zu
realistische Gewaltdarstellungen
enthalten
aber wir müssen natürlich
so realistisch die Simulation auch sind
sie immer noch unterscheiden von den
wirklichen Handlung ob ich einen
Computerspiel
programmiere oder Spiele indem wir
unschuldige Menschen grausam quälen
ist doch immer noch was anderes als ob
ich unschuldige Menschen grausam quälen
oder also es ist ein Unterschied worin
besteht der Unterschied aber
kann man mir Computer spielen dann
vorwerfen wenn ich unschuldige Menschen
dahin Quelle Quelle überhaupt
unschuldige Menschen oder simuliere ich
nicht nur unschuldige Menschen zu quälen
und genauer gefragt simuliere ich nicht
nur simulierte unschuldige Menschen zu
quälen sind ja keine echten Menschen die
ich quäle wenn ich sie simuliere nicht
zu quälen sondern simulierte Menschen
simulierte Menschen die häufig auch
vielleicht fiktive Eigenschaften haben
also sie sehen es ist bin ich so ganz
klar und das hängt entscheidend davon ab
wie wir
auch virtuelle Realität verstehen wir
müssen vor dem Hintergrund des Internets
als virtuellen Handlungsraum genauer
bestimmen was virtuelle Handlungen sind
dabei spielt insbesondere die raum- und
zeitlogik eine zentrale Bedeutung das
habe ich schon oft jetzt angesprochen
das Raum und Zeit eine andere Rolle
spielen es gebe ich ein paar Beispiele
für virtuelle Handlungsräumen soziale
Plattform Kanäle die Facebook Twitter
YouTube sozusagen
wir können natürlich auch Handeln durch
Sprache sprich wir können
informationelle Ethik betreiben auch das
wäre eigentlich dann noch nicht neu ist
der wird schon Handlungsräume
wir müssen aber festhalten dass soziale
Plattform keine Blusen Medien sind die
wir rezipieren oder etwas vermitteln
sondern die agieren durch sie und in
ihnen
noch gravierender wird das Ganze
natürlich wenn es ums wetterversum geht
weil das ist nicht mehr nur textbasiert
Textbotschaften werden da nicht nur
ausgetauscht sondern es werden ja es
wird eine Form von künstlicher Welt
Räumlichkeit erzeugt in der wir uns auch
ja scheinbar bewegen oder wirklich
bewegen das müssen wir noch klären
virtuelle Handlungen um jetzt auf diese
Frage zu kommen bestehen darin
Informationen in einem virtuellen
Handlungsraum zu vernetzen und so diesen
Raum selbst zu verändern ist meine These
also virtuelle Handlung müssen wir nicht
so verstehen dass wir etwas simulieren
alles was wir eben virtuellen
Handlungsraum tun was wir eine Handlung
wird dass wir darin Rennen dass wir
darin kämpfen ist doch erstmal
eine Simulation sie wird dann
realitätshaltig wenn wir diese
Interaktion mit anderen
aber taren durchführen zum Beispiel wenn
wir uns
Bewerb begeben dann simulieren wir
vielleicht immer noch was aber die
Simulation hält auch realistische
Anteile zum Beispiel kann man dann sagen
diese Avatar diese Person hat wirklich
in diesem Spiel gewonnen und sie hat
nicht nur simuliert dabei
bin also auch an andere Personen in den
virtuellen Handlungsraum eintreten Raum
und Zeit hatte ich schon gesagt sind ihr
äußerlich
sie fragen auch nicht so sehr wann war
das im virtuellen Raum wird die Sagen um
3:43
Uhr eher eine andere Rolle spielt es
sind auch damit zusammen das natürlich
die Zeit Einteilung die planetarische
Einzahlung Einteilung Sonnenaufgang
Sonnenuntergang dort gar keine Rolle
spielt das sind jetzt vielleicht
Äußerlichkeiten ich will nicht sagen
dass man nicht auch Dinge datieren kann
aber die Datierung ist viel
problematischer als in unsere physische
gebunden wird so viel steht fest
virtuelle Handlungen sind auch deswegen
problematisch wenn wir fragen wer übt
eigentlich die Handlungen aus das ist
nämlich das virtuelle Subjekt
und dieses virtuelle Subjekt kann den
anonym
existieren ja also
anonym und Pseudonym anonym heißt man
gibt sich gar keinen Namen und Pseudonym
heißt man gibt sich eine fremde
Identität es gibt also verschiedene
Weisen virtuell zu existieren durch
abertaren
das gibt es natürlich auch schon lange
davor
etwa im Chats wenn sie sich ein
Benutzernamen geben es ist häufig auch
ein Pseudonym oder wenn Sie surfen
machen sie das häufig anonym man bekommt
vielleicht Ihre IP-Adresse raus sofern
sie nicht in einem VPN Client sind aber
Ihre IP-Adresse ist kein Name das ist
nur eine Adresse das ist immer noch
anonym idealerweise
wobei natürlich auch durch Metadaten die
sie hinterlassen Spuren die sie im
virtuellen Handlungsraum verlassen sich
ein gutes Profil ihre Persönlichkeit
machen kann also so anonym ist es dann
gar nicht
einem und jetzt möchte ich mal die Frage
aufwerfen wie es eine virtuelle Handlung
zu bewerten gibt's verschiedene
Kriterien so größer die virtuelle
Handlung was auch jetzt immer Zeit den
virtuellen Handel
oder verkleinert sie denn meine These
ist je nachdem wie wir uns im virtuellen
Raum Verhalten sind digitalen Raum
können wir durch unsere Handeln ich habe
gesagt virtuelle hat er was mit
die relationierung zu tun den Verbinden
von
Gegenständen von Informationen je
nachdem wie wird verbindend virtuell
handeln können wir den virtuellen
Handlungsraum vergrößern oder auch
verkleinern das geht natürlich beim
physischen Raum nicht
unseren physischen Raum können wir nicht
vergrößen oder verkleinern weil der Raum
einfach ein Raum ist es gibt
verschiedene Teilbereiche des Raumes ich
kann natürlich ein Haus bauen das
größere kleiner ist aber den Raum
physikalisch betrachtet änder ich
dadurch nicht eine Einschränkung gibt es
natürlich wenn es relativistische
Effekte zu beachten gibt da wird
natürlich Raume Zeit relativ wenn wir
uns in der Nähe der
lichtgeschwindigkeiten befinden ja dann
verkürzen sich auch Strecken aber das
soll jetzt jemand keine Rolle spielen
das heißt der Raum meine These der
virtuelle Raum steht einem viel engeren
Verhältnis zu unserem Handeln zu uns als
der physische Raum tut man kann
natürlich auch in der physischen
Realität der Körper gebundenen Realität
von Handlungsräumen sprechen das kann
man durchaus auch tun dass man
Handlungsräume eröffnet
Informationsräume öffnet nur sind diese
nicht so
technologisch unterstützt medial
unterstützt wie es sich bei diesen
virtuellen Handlungsräumen verhält
deswegen will ich jetzt den Fokus auf
diese Art von Räumen legt oder ein
Beispiel geben ich kann den virtuellen
Handlungsraum vergrößern wenn ich zum
Beispiel dafür sorge durch mal dass
durch meine Vernetzung meine Verbindung
sich freies Wissen idealerweise
vergrößend meine These wäre ich kann zum
Beispiel dadurch virtuell handeln dass
ich an Wikipedia Mitarbeiter oder
Informationen im Internet miteinander
sinnvoll verknüpfen das kann sein dass
ich zum Beispiel auch in Wikipedia neue
Einträge schreibe oder bestehende
Artikel miteinander vernetzt also den
Netzwerkgedanke ist für den virtuellen
Raum ganz wichtig damit vergröße ich ihn
weil ich meine Orientierung vergrößere
ich kann im Cyberspace besser navigieren
ich kann dann im Cyberspace besser
navigieren wenn er
verletzt ist wenn er
nachvollziehbar ist spricht es geht hier
um logisch Eigenschaften ein also ganz
stark auch im systemische Einstellungen
die wir nicht nur einnehmen zum
virtuellen Handlungsraum sondern die wir
selbst mit leisten
wir gestalten den virtuellen
Handlungsraum
erkundbar navigieren
nicht erkundbar da schrumpft der
virtuelle Handlungsraum und filterblasen
weil wir uns nun unser eigenes univers
informationsuniversum drehen ne ganz
spezielle Frage ist auch noch das
Darknet das müssen wir auch noch
diskutieren als eine Form des
schrumpfenden handlungsraums würde ich
mal sagen obwohl viele sagen würden im
Darknet kann ich doch tun was ich will
das ist so eine Vergrößerung ist
wir müssen natürlich hier auch immer
wieder fragen was für eine Freiheit ich
habe nämlich jetzt Handlung angesprochen
da muss man auch den Begriff der
Freiheit ein Spiel bringen und was für
eine Freiheit geht's hier geht's um die
Freiheit tun zu können was man will die
Handlungsfreiheit oder geht's um die
Frage mein wollen selbst bestimmen zu
können das ist die Willensfreiheit und
Willensfreiheit ist viel anspruchsvoller
als Handlungsfreiheit
das müssen wir mal dahingestellt lassen
vielleicht gibt's auch eine neue Form
von Freiheit sowas wie virtuelle
Freiheit
gut das möchte ich jetzt hier nicht
weiter ausführen das nehmen wir mal
vielleicht mit in die letzte Sitzung am
Freitag wenn es um die Anthropologie
geht ich möchte jetzt aber mal auf das
Problem der Verkleinerung es virtuellen
handlungsraums eingehen und zwar anhand
eines ganz prominenten Philosophen der
nicht unweit von hier lebt nämlich in
starrenberg sie ahnen schon wer das ist
das ist der Jürgen habermaß der war ja
auch schon ein paar mal hier an der Uhr
er hat ein Buch geschrieben neuerdings
ein neues verwandel der Öffentlichkeit
und was sagte darin es scheint sich bei
exklusiven Nutzern sozialer Medien damit
meinte natürlich er sagt es nicht so der
meint natürlich die virtuellen
Handlungsräume eine Weise der halb
öffentlichen fragmentierten und in sich
kreisenden Kommunikation durchzusetzen
er spricht nur von Kommunikation nicht
von Handlung das ist hängt damit
zusammen dass er einfach auf dem paradig
mal der Kommunikation seine ganze
Philosophie entfaltet sie kennen die
Theorie des kommunikativen Handelns
handeln wird kommunikativ
eine in sich kreisende Kommunikation
durchsetzt ist natürlich eine Blase die
er meint die deren Wahrnehmung von
politischer Öffentlichkeit als solche
deformiert der Handlungsraum wird der
formiert der wird eingeschränkt der wird
beschnitten der wird zum Schrumpfen
gebracht wenn diese Vermutung zutrifft
wird bei einem wachsenden Teil der
Staatsbürger eine wichtige subjektive
Voraussetzung für den mehr oder weniger
der liberativen Modus der meinungs- und
Willensbildung gefährdet die liberativ
heißt abwägen er muss sich Gründung
gegen Gründe bekommen die muss ich von
außen bekommen und zwar durch andere
Subjekte die auch mal Kritik üben und
nicht durch eine Blase die mich immer
nur selbst bestätigt und die immer nur
das bestärkt was ich angekommen wollte
oder wollen werde oder wollt also sie
sehen das ist ganz zentral er macht es
mit seiner Begrifflichkeit die natürlich
nicht adäquat ist für virtuelle Realität
aber die eben seinem sprach Philosoph
Paradigma geschuldet ist wir haben dann
hier noch einen Aufsatz auch ganz neu
letztes Jahr vor letztes Jahr
und jetzt wird eine Kritik geübt an der
Ökonomisierung das ist auch ein Punkt
den wir ja unbedingt behandeln müssen
denn diese real existierende neue Medien
er spricht nicht von virtuellen
Handlungsräumen von neuen Medien
Facebook Youtube Instagram oder Twitter
habe ich jetzt hinzugefügt er nennt die
nicht er ist wahrscheinlich auch nicht
auf diesen neuen Medien zumindest ist er
nicht bei mir befreundet mit mir auf
Facebook
schaue immer heute Abend wurde auch
drauf ist sind Unternehmen oder auch
Instagram hat Unternehmen die
Imperativen der Kapitalverwertung
gehorchen und dann der Börse zu
exportierten Konzern gehören Meta und
vor allem natürlich Apple
ihre Gewinne verdanken sie der
Verwertung von Daten die sie zu
Werbezwecken oder anderweit die als
wahren veräußern also so gut eigennützig
sind diese virtuellen Handlungsräume
auch nicht die diese großen Unternehmen
uns da eröffnen sondern sie sind daran
interessiert dass sie uns letztendlich
zu Zutaten Objekten generieren und am
Ende unsere Interaktionen zu Geld machen
zu fahren Geld noch ein Zitat in einer
schwer vorstellbaren Welt von Fake News
nicht mehr als solche identifiziert also
von waren verschieden werden könnten
würde kein Kind aufwachsen können eine
klinische Symptome zu haben Fake News
verbreiten sich natürlich auch in der
analogen Welt
aber vielleicht auf eine ganz besondere
Weise in der virtuellen Welt und
deswegen meine These jetzt die virtuelle
digitale Welt oder die Handlungsräume
die stellen uns von neu indische
Probleme bisher sagt er nur analog zu
dem
sozialen Problemen die wir ohnehin schon
hatten ich glaube es gibt neue Probleme
und die möchte ich Ihnen jetzt zeigen
anhand dieses Buches und Elite Paris
hatte Filter Bubble und die deutsche
Übersetzung lautet ich finde es sehr
treffen wie wir im Internet entmündigt
werden
hier wird also auf dem Begriff der
Aufklärung angespielt sie wissen ja
erkannt hat der Mündigkeit
mit dem Kontext seine Theorie der
Aufklärung verwendet
und jetzt kommt der Punkt wo ich sagen
würde der virtuelle Handlungsraum der
stellt uns von neue Problemen sagt
nämlich Prognose Maschinen der
Übersetzung entwerfen und verfeinert
pausenlos eine Theorie zu Ihrer
Persönlichkeit sagen voraus was Sie als
nächstes tun und wollen zusammen
schaffen diese Maschinen ein ganz
eigenes
universumationsuniversum ein
Handlungsraum für jeden von uns das was
er die filterpar benennt und verändern
zu auf fundamentale Weise Informationen
das ist jetzt doch was Neues oder also
sowas gut blasen gibt's natürlich auch
in der sozialen Welt wir sind immer
unter unseren gleichen in der Regel sehr
Geschicht und so sehr das Bildungsniveau
selbst Alter aber das ist doch noch mal
was anderes hier oder weil die Blase
wird ja hier fremd bestimmt durch
Algorithmen die nicht mehr unbedingt
direkt darauf eine Person zurückzuführen
sind so verhält sich da mit den Blasen
und unsere sozialen Welt nicht ja also
das ist nur meine Verkomplizierung
zumindest vielleicht sogar was ganz
neues deswegen glaube ich müssen wir
hier schon mal die Frage aufwerfen ob
sie nicht neue Probleme gibt da man die
Kriterien mit denen Websites Information
Filter nicht selbst festgelegt hat hält
man die Informationen die in die Filter
Babel gelangen für neutral objektiv und
war so ist es aber nicht wenn man einmal
steckt ist es Beine unmöglich zu
erkennen wie sie vorgefasst ist
epistemische Heteronomie informationelle
Fremdbestimmung die aber natürlich nicht
nur so zu verstehen ist dass wir
admindig werden wie der Titel hier
angibt sondern wenn Sie Manuel Kant
gelesen haben weil wir uns selbst
entmündigen kann sprich von einer
selbstverschuldeten Unmündigkeit und
nicht von einer fremdverschuldeten
das muss man hier natürlich noch
korrigieren wir selbst sind die Ursache
dafür dass wir uns in solche Blasen
gegeben nicht einfach nur sind wir
Objekte und
Opfer der großen Unternehmen sind wir
selbst haben
also diesen Autonomie Gedanken möchte
ich immer noch hervorheben
jetzt haben wir das Internet ein
bisschen diskutiert Internet ist Old
School Internet ist Generation
und gestern jetzt gibt's die Generation
Z dass metaver so Ethik des perversum es
wird wirklich spannend
jetzt möchte ich Ihnen von Mark
Zuckerberg dem Chef von Facebook ehemals
heute Mittag ein kurzes oder auch ein
bisschen längeres Werbevideo vorstellen
nicht dass sie jetzt sagen das ist ja
eine reine Werbeveranstaltung jetzt
haben wir hier Apple diskutiert und so
weiter und so fort wir haben uns dann
viel mehr angeschaut dann so ist jetzt
nicht aus sondern wie immer wir schauen
uns den Film oder diesen Ausschnitt
natürlich aus kritischer Perspektive
mündiger Perspektive an und befragen ihn
auf diese Fragen hin wie wird in dem
Video was Sie gleich sehen ist ein
Werbevideo Mark Zuckerberg zum ersten
Mal meine es ist vorstellen wie wird das
Wetter wäre es um charakterisiert
generell was ist das Wetter was machen
Sie sich gerne Notiz nehmen sich ein
Blatt heraus während sich das Video
anschauen notieren Sie sich Ihre
Ergebnisse was ist seine Hauptaufgabe
des Metalls worum geht's
wie schließt es mit perversum als Marke
auch an die her bisherigen Marken
Facebook an wie findet der Begriff
achten Sie gut drauf ich glaube es ist
laut genug gestellt der Begriff virtuell
gebraucht
verwendete inwiefern wird im metaverso
gehandelt liefern ist es ein virtuelle
Handlungsraum wie finden werden die
Aktivitäten als Handlungen dargestellt
nicht nur als Konsum
im liefern handelt es sich bei
Metaversum so wie es dort dargestellt
wird um eine Simulation
umgedreht gefragt inwiefern nach unseren
Begriffen meine virtuelle Realität
welche Aspekte des metaphersums dürfen
wir guten Gewissens nach uns sind
Kriterien virtuelle Realität nämlich
inwiefern ist das Facebook
problematisch denken Sie an kommerzielle
Dinge denken sie an andere Möglichkeiten
die das ganze ethisch problematisch
erscheinen lassen ja schauen sich ruhig
noch ein bisschen die Punkte an es sind
einige es sind genau sechs Stück und
machen sie sich zu jedem Punkt ihre
Gedanken und wenn Sie bereit sind würde
ich einfach jetzt mal mit dem Video
beginnen
muss ich merke hier ich muss wohl noch
den Ton anmachen
deswegen halte ich jetzt die
Aufzeichnung an
ja wir haben uns dieses Werbevideo von
Mark Zuckerberg beim Meta über die
Einführung des metapörsums kritisch
angeschaut wir haben es nicht blenden
lassen wir haben diese Fragen hier alle
diskutiert was ist das Motto gewesen
Menschen zusammenzubringen Menschen zu
verbinden das klingt jetzt erstmal wie
ein Heeres Ziel ja wie ein spannendes
Thema wie ein ja praktisch schon fast
schon ein Wohltätigkeit wie eine
Wohltätigkeitsorganisation
dann haben wir gesehen Datenschutz wird
ganz kurz angesprochen und wir haben
gesehen wir werden Räume suggeriert
nicht nur simuliert sonst suggeriert die
nicht unser Leben Wirklichkeit
entsprechen und die würden ja als
Simulationen Alltags dargestellt
dass wir unseren Alltag mitbringen in
das Wetter werden
am Ende eine Utopie wird uns da
irgendwie eine
eine Wunsch Welt vorgegaukelt in die wir
uns flüchten können wieder Stichwort
Eskapismus das will er natürlich nicht
zu sagen
wir sollen unsere Realität erweitern er
spricht von der
Erweiterung und hat ganz ähnlich auch
wie Apple Vision pro hatte hier eine
Szene eingebracht wo wir
die Software oder das Tool WhatsApp
sagen was ja facebook gehört a oder Meta
gehört was wir in den Raum hinein
projiziert haben das ist also auch gibt
verschiedene versuchen
er hat ab und zu kurz den Begriff
virtuell gebraucht virtual hat er gesagt
jedoch nicht in dem spezifischen Sinn
meines Wissens war das kompatibel mit
Simulation wir haben dann auch noch
einen wichtigen Punkt gesehen nämlich
seine Verdopplung als Avatar sie haben
gemeint der sieht jetzt schon aus wie
ein Avatar so so ganz ganz sozusagen
geglättet eine künstlich er hat ein
Avatar gespiegelt bekommen der
virtuellen Welt und hat dann mit dem
Finger geschnippt oder irgendwie ein
Zeichen gegeben hat dieser aber da seine
Kleidung gewechselt mal kurz waren
Halloween Kleidung darunter am Ende hat
er diese Version gewählt der ihm
entsprach das kann man sich fragen ist
es eine Simulation der aber tatsächlich
selbst wir haben Kamera Schwenk gesehen
wo dann die Kamera in den Kopf des aber
das Nein gesungen hat sozusagen sowas
hat mir bisschen nur gesehen seine
Kamera schwenkt wenn es um den Sohn in
die virtuelle Realität bringen
bei
ready Player one oder bei Apple Vision
pro haben wir diesen Schwenk gesehen
jetzt geht in den Avatar rein also ist
ja aber keine Verdopplung
eine Simulation oder agieren wir durch
diesen Avatar wirklich oder simulieren
wir durch den Avatar ist ja aber da eine
Simulation von uns oder eine Virtualität
Virtualisierung
spannende Frage das müssen wir mal ganz
gezielt nachdem bereits präsentierten
Kriterien untersuchen und mal wieder
eine Pause und danach geht's zum Thema
Selbstversuche mit pervers und wie fühlt
sich das eigentlich an wenn man das mal
drei Tage lang macht wird man dann auch
irgendwelche klinischen Schäden bekommen
wie Jürgen Hammermeister vermutet hat in
einer Welt von Fake News in einer Welt
der Simulation oder auch wirklichen will
Virtualität ist das für unsere
Gesundheit gut muss man ja auch mal
fragen
leben wenn wir richtig gesagt wurde wenn
einem dunklen Kämmer abgeschieden sitzen
und trotzdem den Eindruck haben die
Simulation oder die Wirklichkeit mit
anderen Leuten interagieren simulieren
mit anderen Menschen mit perversen oder
realisieren wir sind
wirklich hier ist natürlich wieder das
Stichwort fensterlose simulade
werden wir nur koordiniert oder
interagieren wir wirklich
nachdem wir uns Mark Zuckerbergs
Werbevideo angeschaut haben was das
Metaversum eingeführt hat
was auf Hochglanz getrimmt war wir sahen
schöne hohe Decken die keiner
Lebenswirklichkeit entsprechend
vielleicht nur derjenige von Mark
Zuckerberg selbst jedenfalls nicht vom
normalen nutze den normalen Nutzerin
wollen wir uns mal Gedanken machen wie
das Wetter wäre zum wirklich aussieht
und dazu gibt's hier von den Reportern
YouTube Kanal Reporter offiziell eine
sehr spannende Dokumentation die ich
auch sehr empfehlen kann wo eine dieser
Reporter sich drei Tage lang ins Wetter
wäre so begeben hat also mal den
Alltagstest gemacht hat nicht mal nur so
fünf Minuten mal so zehn Minuten mal
reinschnuppern und antesten sondern
wirklich leben Stichwort online live ne
das sind Luciano Florida geprägt hat
diesen Begriff und jetzt wollen wir uns
natürlich fragen wenn wir uns das jetzt
anschauen
wie unterscheidet sich die Präsentation
die Darstellung die Realität des
metaversubs in dieser Reportage von der
Darstellung bei sackabwehr gibt es da
Unterschiede dass die erste Frage die
zweite Frage ist welche Aktionen werden
jetzt hier in dieser Reportage gezeigt
also welche virtuellen Handlungen werden
wir verzogen inwiefern handelt es sich
um Handlungen um Simulation oder
Illusion und die nächste und letzte
Frage ist wie begegnen uns darin andere
Subjekte durch Avatare sind das
Simulationen von anderen Personen
Illusionen oder andere Form von
Realisation achten Sie mal darauf auch
auf die Motive welche diese Personen
dazu bewegt ins Metaversum zu gehen und
dort virtuell zu handeln sofern es sich
wirklich um eine virtuelle Handlung
handelt wir schauen uns jetzt den Film
diesen Ausschnitt sie Dokumentation sind
Ausschnitt aus Dokumentation ist nicht
die gesamte Dokumentation gemeinsam an
und diskutieren im Anschluss die
genannten Fragen
wir haben uns etwas diese Reportage
angeschaut die kann ich sehr empfehlen
unten habe ich den Link dazu rein
gemacht diese Reporter ist drei Tage
lang ins metterversum eingetaucht der
hat sich eine künstliche Welt geschafft
er hat jeglichen Kontakt mit anderen
Menschen dieser Zeit vermieden um
wirklich nur über das wetterversum
soziale interagieren und wir haben
verschiedenes gesehen dieses mit
perversum was er uns präsentiert ist
nicht so auch Hochglanz getrimmt wie das
Werbevideo von Mark Zuckerberg wir haben
verschiedene Meinungen gehört
aber Tage und die Motive sich im
Mittagessen aufzuhalten bestanden darin
dass man sich noch schützen möchte ja
schützen möchte vor verurteilen man
zeigt nicht seine Verletzlichkeit durch
den physischen Körper sondern nutzt den
avatarten auf eines virtuellen
Schutzschildes oder zumindest in einer
Maske das haben wir auch daran gesehen
dass es dort auch zu einem virtuellen
Theaterspiel er kam ein Partyspiel wo
man sich fragen konnte ist das jetzt
wirkliches Theater oder nur simuliertes
Theater der Reporter hatte darüber sich
amüsiert gezeigt als es liegt nahe sein
es ist wirkliches spielen jetzt kann man
sich fragen welche Rolle spielte Avatar
ihr könnte man sagen es ist eine
Theatermaske die nur eine virtuelle
Theatermaske insofern würde auch Theater
spielen so nicht nur eine Simulation von
Theater spielen sein sondern ein
wirkliches Theater hier ergeben sich
eben interessante Bezüge zu Ästhetik zu
fragen nach dem Verhältnis von Ästhetik
und Virtualität beide haben gewisse
Dinge gemeinsam ich würde aber
argumentieren es gibt ein Unterschied
und der besteht darin dass virtuelle
Realität ethisch bewertbar sein muss
während die Debatte
unterschiedliche Auffassung kennen wenn
es um die Frage nach dem ästhetischen
gibt
Auffassungen die sagen Ethik und
Ästhetik müssen aufeinander bezogen
werden zum Beispiel sagen sie haben
haben die Autorin und Autorinnen eines
Buches eines Romans auch Beantwortung
für das was sie schreiben
während andere Auffassung sagen der
Autor die Autorin ist tot interessiert
uns gar nicht wir nehmen nur den Text
und Fragen nicht auf irgendwelche
Intentionen des kulturs der Atomen das
wäre unästhetisch sagen genauso spricht
dagegen die Auffassung der Kunst als
Kunst Lara die eben schon seit Ende des
19 bis 18 Jahrhunderts um 1800 der
Klassik durch Goethe und Moritz schon im
Grunde Autonomie der Kunst diskutiert
wurde und dann natürlich im 19
Jahrhundert noch viel stärker vertreten
wurde denken Sie an die Blumen des Bösen
flirtimal wo in die Ästhetik und die das
hässliche an Bedeutung gewonnen wo eben
die Kunst die eigentlich
um einen schönen Handel das hässliche
gedichtet hat
weil ich davon das Gedicht erinnern was
sie in diesen dieser ant
iologie
beschrieben da wird die sind ihre
Grenzen gebracht sogar die moralischen
Grenzen und das wird gerade als
ästhetisch interpretiert mit dem Moral
mit dem Anstand in Konflikt zu werden
das ist ein ästhetischer
aber hier gibt es wie gesagt viele
Auffassung davon und wir haben gesehen
der arme Reporter hatte nach einem Tag
schon furchtbare Schmerzen im Auge er
hat davor gewarnt dass wenn man das
länger macht sogar Verbrennungen der
Netzhaut allein kann wir haben
festgestellt dass hier ist jetzt Mittel
und da wurde noch mit Controllern
interagiert da war die Körperlichkeit
irgendwie noch nicht so ganz geschmeidig
einbezogen während wenn sie sich die App
Bewerbung noch mal anschauen sehen sie
ziemlich der Körper wird selbst zum
Kunstwerk damit der Brille hier
meditiert
also solche Effekte würde Apple nie
erdulden man muss sich natürlich fragen
ob die Brille wirklich so
ist das ist natürlich auch eine
physiologische Frage die nicht ganz
unabhängig davon zu beurteilen ist ja
und jetzt würde ich sagen kommen wir auf
das nächste Thema zu sprechen das ist
nämlich jetzt beim Horizon worlds
mit ihm diskutieren so sieht dieses
Logo aus sie sehen hier ganz klein sehen
sie hiermiter angegeben wird zu Metall
was Vorlesen was denn eigentlich Horizon
wird
Horizont wird Facebook Reisen ist es
free Virtual Reality online video game
wir sind integrade Game creation System
September 19 Wikipedia
[Musik]
und jetzt möchte ich Ihnen im nächsten
Video heute haben wir sehr viele Videos
möchte ich Ihnen auch wieder ein eine
Werbung präsentieren das sollte jetzt
Oculus Quest 2 sein oder metacrist 2 das
sehen Sie an diesen Controller
vergleichen Sie das mal mit der Apple
wischen all da sehen sie vorne ist hier
eine Abdeckung sie schauen durch bei
applevision Pro wird zumindest simuliert
oder durch Kameratechnik erreicht das
sieht durchschauen sie haben eine
Transparenz also keine fensterlose
munade sozusagen ja und sie haben hier
noch die handcontrollen die fallen bei
Apple Mission pro Weg dann haben sie nur
ihren Körper als Medium als
Schnittstelle
Realität schauen Sie sich jetzt mal
dieses Video kurz an und untersuchen sie
dann sortieren sie sich wieder die
Antwort auf die Frage in diesem handelt
es sich hierbei virtuelle Realität wie
wird hier interagiert und wie verhält
sich Horizon worlds zum Mittagszug was
ja kaputt vorgestellt hatte
wie können wir darin handeln und welche
Probleme des Handelns begeben sich und
dann lassen wir alles wieder zusammen
wir haben gesehen dass Horizon worlds im
Vergleich zu den anderen Dingen die wir
gesehen haben im Metaversum sehr bunt
ist sehr ja spielerisch vielleicht auch
sich an ein jüngeres Publikum wendet wir
müssen auch noch dazu sagen dass die
Kommunikation im Metaversum wie es uns
bisher präsentiert wird häufig reduziert
ist ja wir haben nicht dieselbe Mimik es
wird versucht die Mimik zu simulieren
wir haben nicht denselben Augenkontakt
wir wissen dass Kommunikation nicht nur
über die Semantik läuft was sind auch
Lohn und paraveral funktioniert deswegen
hat auch im Metaversum die Hand eine
Entsprechung eines simulierte
Entsprechung also die Gestik wird
versucht zu simulieren ich sage jetzt
nicht zu virtualisieren man versucht sie
zu simulieren weil einfach die
Kommunikation so entscheidend auch über
die Hand läuft
Gerüche spielen keine Rolle sie müssten
simuliert werden das heißt unsere
Kommunikation ist sehr eingeschränkt man
muss jetzt auf der anderen Seite fragen
ob vielleicht sich nicht trotzdem neue
Formen von Kommunikation eröffnet wenn
es sich um virtuelle Realität handeln
sollte dann müsste per Definition
zumindest nach unserer Definition nicht
auch eine neue Form von Kommunikation
eröffnen die dann vielleicht auch neue
ethische Probleme mit sich ziehen ich
möchte jetzt nur auf ein ethisches
Problem eingehen was schon in Horizon
world beobachtet wurde und zwar
folgendes und 206 November 2018
ja also
da kam jemand
virtuell eine andere Person zu nahe von
Belästigung virtueller Belästigung in
February 200 Meter in responsed für die
incidence addit am Ende Tory Personal
bauen to Reisen worlds and values which
creates invisible
von Avatar if and ables which build on
top of existent Feature mit makes Users
hands disappear is the god too closed
also dass man da nicht gegen den Willen
virtuell angefasst wird
also da muss wohl ein Avatar einen
anderen Avatar zu nahe gekommen sein und
die Hände zu nahe an diesen anderen
gebracht haben so dass jetzt darauf
reagiert wird dass die Hände
verschwimmen wenn man zu nahmen kommt
und die virtuelle Komfortzone wurde auch
ausgeweit ja wurde jetzt da eine Person
wirklich belästigt oder nur
virtuell im Sinne des Simulation die
Wirkung war dieselbe die Person hat sich
belästigt gefühlt also hätte man gute
Gründe zu sagen es war nicht nur eine
simulierte Belästigung das war nicht
wirkliche beläst also jetzt kann man
sich natürlich fragen ist es jetzt was
ganz anderes als in der physischen Welt
nein hier stellt sich kein neues Problem
in der physischen Welt können uns Leute
zu nahe kommen wenn wir es nicht wollen
und der virtuellen Welt zumindest in
dieser Welt wenn man mit Avataren
interagiert dann auch also hier stellen
Sie jetzt auch erstmal keine neuen
Probleme man kann jetzt allerdings das
ganze so regeln und das geht in der
physischen Welt nicht dass man Barrieren
einbaut noch geht's nicht vielleicht
kann man irgendwann so Schutzzonen
sowieso Laser Hüllen oder sowas wo man
dran kommt eine elektrischen Schlag
bekommt installieren aber das müsste
jeder selbst machen hier wird es von
oben sozusagen verordnet hier kann man
das rein programmieren also es ändert
sich wieder so ein bisschen was weil es
eben digital ist und entsprechend
manipulierbar ist ja
man jetzt individuell die Komfortzone
erweitern und vergrößern wie mit einem
Schieberegler das dann jeder Avatar
selbst sagen kann Komfortzone auf oder
so auf 30%
natürlich auch am Ende eine individuelle
Frage wir wissen auch dass Komfortzone
kulturell durchaus abhängig sind dass
das auch kulturell eine gewisse Prägung
haben kann so jetzt frage ich sollten
die metaphersum auch moralische Regeln
gelten zu wenig und wie sollten Sie
genau beschaffen sein hier war jetzt
schon mal das Angebot von forzone
virtuelle Komfortzone oder Hände
verschwinden virtuelle Hände über
simulierte Hände verschwinden wenn sie
einem anderen aber da zu nahe kommen
wir müssen auch uns noch Gedanken machen
über virtuelle Identität virtuelle
Personen Personen können virtuellen
Handlungsraum des Internets verschiedene
Rollen einnehmen das habe ich schon
gesagt Personen können anonym oder
pseudonym existieren Masken sich
vorsetzen
Personen können im Internet durch
Avatare interagieren insbesondere in
Computerspiele und Computerspiele werden
immer weniger als konsummedien immer
mehr als virtuelle Handlungsräume
sichtbar warum weil wir Computer immer
mehr online spielen und weil wir immer
mehr Darstellungsformen haben die uns
auch Räumlichkeit suggerieren
jetzt kommen wir noch kurz auf
Computerspiele zu sprechen auf die
kommen auch noch zu sprechen Morgen wenn
es um die Ästhetik der virtuellen
Realität geht die eine ethische
Bewertung von Computerspielen hängt
davon ab ob wir Computerspiele als bloße
Spiele betrachten als neue Medien als
Fiktionen oder ästhetische Produkte dann
stellt sie wieder das Problem von
Ethikern als Simulationen oder als
virtuelle Realität
das ganze entscheiden wie wir sie
verstehen es gibt ganz verschiedene
Auffassungen die USK die
Unterhaltungssoftware Selbstkontrolle da
mache ich oben rechts wieder Meter rein
die versteht Computerspiele als
Unterhaltungsmedien
Unterhaltungssoftware
ja
Computerspiele haben aber ganz häufig
fiktionalen Gehalt und auch ästhetischen
Gehalt Computerspiele werden häufig auch
als Kunstwerk angesehen
im Computerspielen interagieren wir aber
auch teilweise wirklich zum Beispiel in
Diablo 4 oder in
second-agieren mit virtuellen
Gegenständen die einen großen Wert haben
dann liegt es nachher eher von Virtual
Realität zu sprechen oder wenn wir Werte
erzeugen im Computer spielen die wir
verkaufen können dann ist es nicht nur
Simulation wenn wir mit nfts mit non
funchable Jokern mit virtuellen
Gegenständen im Computerspiel
interagieren dann ist es nicht nur eine
Simulation und auch nicht nur ein Spiel
das hat einen wirklichen Wert das hat er
was ökonomisches schon fast was
natürlich immer noch im Kontexten des
Spiels eingebunden ist
Computerspiele können jetzt aus ganz
verschiedenen Gründen moralisch
problematisch sein sie sind
gewaltverherrlichen und werden deswegen
teilweise indiziert sie diskriminieren
andere Menschen
jetzt kann man sich aber wiederum Fragen
sind die Inhalte von Computerspielen
nicht durch das Grundrecht auf freie
Meinungsäußerungen und Freiheit der
Kunst gedeckt hängt wieder davon ab was
Sie glauben was ein Computerspiel ist
wenn es ein Kunstwerk ist dann schon
aber computerspiele sind eben mehr als
bloße Kunstwerke weil wir darin eben
auch moralisch relevant interagieren
können computerspiele sind mehr als nur
meinungsäuße und Kunstwerke sondern
wirklichkeitsverhandlungen je mehr in
einem Computer spielt unmoralisches
detailliert simuliert wird desto
moralisch problematische erscheint ist
ist ja immer noch eine Simulation aber
eine Simulation hatte immer fragen
dürfte immer Fragen auf warum wird das
hier sind zu welchem Zweck soll ich
jetzt unschuldige Menschen töten warum
muss ich das in jedem Detail simulieren
das wirft Fragen auf die ethische Art
sind
das Grundrecht der freien
Meinungsäußerung Artikel 5 Absatz 1
Grundgesetz
gibt natürlich
dem Ästhetik viel viele mit die Grenzen
der meinungs- und Kunstfreiheit werden
in anderen Ländern zum Teil
unterschiedlich gehandelt in USA werden
Gewaltdarstellung meist unkritischer
bewertet wegen wogegen für Pornografie
wesentlich schärferem Maßstäbe angelegt
werden in als in Deutschland ja also die
Meinungsfreiheit wird ein kann dann
eingeschränkt werden wenn es um die
Beeinträchtigung wichtige Rechtsgüter
geht wie etwa dem Jugendschutz da hörte
Meinungsfreiheit auf und da hört auch
die Freiheit der Kunst auf und deswegen
gibt es die USK die
Unterhaltungssoftware selbst kommt worin
besteht jetzt der ethische Unterschied
muss man fragen einem Buch würden
moralisch problematisch Passagen erzählt
bzw erdichtet einen Film werden
moralisch problematische Passagen
gespielt beziehungsweise auch
in einem Computerspiel werden moralisch
problematisch Passagen selbst gespielt
bzw simuliert durch den Avatar oder
durch ein Akteur
und jetzt müssen wir uns fragen welches
im Bereich philosophische paratigma
eignet sich am besten um Computerspiele
ethisch zu bewerten und überhaupt
virtuelle Realitäten am besten zu
bewerten die deontologie wird die Würde
der spielenden Person oder andere Person
dadurch verletzt lassen sich die Motive
im Computerspiel vernünftig
verallgemeinern liegen dem Computerspiel
Maximen zugrunde subjektive
Handlungsgrundsätze die ich nicht
vernünftig verallgemeinern kann wenn ich
so spielen würde aber ich spiele doch
nur und handle nicht kann spricht davon
Handlungen Maximen sind
Handlungsgrundsätze subjektive hier
werden das ja nur subjektiven
spielgrundsätze
konsequentialismus sind die Konsequenz
des computerspielens für die Spielende
Person oder andere Person schlecht sind
ja folgendes schlecht aber ist doch nur
ein Spiel könnte man Antworten ein Spiel
ist keine Handlung als sind die Folgen
doch völlig egal
und tugenethik verschlechtert sich der
moralische Charakter der spielenden
Person durch das Computerspiel ja da
scheint so ein bisschen eine Substanz
gegeben zu sein wer häufig sehr brutale
Computerspiele spielt zu sagen zumindest
manche der läuft Gefahr dass sein
Charakter sich vielleicht auch dadurch
beeinflussen ist auf der anderen Seite
könnte man sagen liebe im Computerspiel
die Aggression rauslassen aber nicht in
der physischen Realität oder der harten
Wirklichkeit das wäre die sogenannte
kathar Systemtheorie da muss man jetzt
die Psychologin und Psychologen fragen
was sie davon halten beide Theorien sind
problematisch ja
wir wollen ja aber keine Psychologie
anstellen sondern knallharte Philosophie
machen das heißt wir müssen nicht nur
auf die Wirkungen ausgehen wir müssen
uns fragen was sind eigentlich
computerspiele sind es Simulationen sind
es Handlung und davon dann ausgehen
Fragen aufwerfen die die moralischen
Bewertung
Computerspiele jedenfalls Geld nicht
mehr nur als Zeitvertreib und nutzlose
Spielereien werden immer mehr ästhetisch
und philosophisch als interessante
Phänomene ernst genommen
computerspiele sind nicht nur
Spielereien und konsummedien
Computerspiele sind viel mehr
experimentierfelder auf den spielerisch
die Verhältnisse von Realität Simulation
Fiktion und Illusion erprobt werden als
manche sprechen auch von pseudo oder
Proto Handel was ich dort abspielt
also wir verhandeln darin die
Wirklichkeit und wir stellen komplexe
möglichkeitsverhältnisse her wir loben
die ontologischen Grenzen der
Wirklichkeit der illusionssimulation aus
und darin zeigt sich eine gewisse
moralische Relevanz ich habe deswegen
zweimal gebracht ja so viel für heute
wir sehen um ethische Fragen stellen zu
können müssen wir erst philosophisch
begrifflich sicherstellen um was sich
das beurteilte eigentlich handelt wir
können von ästhetischen Phänomen wir
müssen von ästhetischen Phänomen anders
sprechen Blick auf moralische Bewertung
als von
real die nicht nur eine künstliche Form
besitzen dennoch scheint die Kunst nicht
ganz davor gefeit zu sein auch nach
moralischen Kriterien urteilt zu werden
zumindest haben wir starke Tendenzen das
zu tun und jetzt stellt sich natürlich
die Frage virtuelle Realität Verstand
nicht nur als Simulation wobei man auch
bei Simulation Fragen kann wie man sie
moralisch zu bewerten hat verstehen wir
aber virtuelle Realität nicht nur als
Simulation sondern als neuartige zum
Beispiel digital
realisierte Welt dann scheinen doch auch
die ethischen Normen dort zu gelten hier
stellen sich zwei weitere Fragen gelten
sie analog zur physischen Welt oder
brauchen wir neue Regeln weil virtuelle
Realität uns von neu ethische Probleme
stellen die mit der Raum zeitlogik zu
tun haben die mit dem ontologischen
Status zu tun haben und so weiter die
auch mit unserer virtuellen Existenz
zugrunde haben weil sie vielleicht darin
gar nicht mehr so sehr leiblich präsent
sind sprich unsere Körperlichkeit die
dort nicht vorliegt könnte Auswirkungen
haben auf die ethische Bewertung
dabei möchte ich jetzt mal belassen wir
beenden die Aufzeichnung und ich gebe
jetzt noch einen kurzen Ausblick auf die
nächste vorlesen